hey there starcraft two fans today we're
excited to show you a series of changes
arriving with patch 2.1 we've got a lot
of awesome things to talk about so first
let's start with the arcade with patch
2.1 the arcade is now free this means
you your friends and anyone else can
simply download the free starcraft 2
starter edition and play any of the
games in the arcade in addition custom
games will also be completely accessible
to starter Edition users to complement
this we're implementing a feature called
extension mods extension mods are sets
of rules that can be applied to any map
in the game this will make for custom
game types that can be played across any
of the maps in starcraft 2 to give you
an idea of how these will work we've
gone ahead and put in three starter mods
all units explode big game hunters
and wandering minerals we're all so
excited to share that we've added three
new features to the way you get to
interact and share Starcraft 2 with
others the first is the addition of
events events are scheduled meetups
which can be set by a clan or groups
owner and officers they allow you to set
a title date description and duration so
that it's easy to get the word out that
something's going down we've also wanted
to give our social groups even more
character so we've added the ability for
groups and clans to have custom icons
represent your team and stand behind
your symbol as groups and clans will be
much more easily identified speaking of
symbols we've also made it possible for
you to upload an image as a clan decal
previously decals were icons you chose
that surrounded your main structure and
appeared on some units and buildings
with patch 2.1 you'll now be able to fly
your clans customized decal over your
base for friend and foe to see have you
noticed the background music by the way
with patch 2.1 the original starcraft
and starcraft broodwar soundtracks have
been remastered and implemented into the
game you'll find the options to enable
them in the sound section of the options
menu with all of these changes there's a
lot that's new to the game so we've
added some extra progress and
unlockables for you level caps have been
extended from 30 to 35 for each race
first win of the day bonuses have been
increased to 100,000 XP and we've added
new and awesome portraits and decals
courtesy of our friend John Burton of
carbot animations patch 2.1 is here in
starcraft 2 has never had so much to
offer thanks for watching and we'll see
you online